I like my women the way I like my skis
rented as a kid my dad used to always
hit me with a camera I still have
flashbacks to homeless people really get
knock-knock jokes
growing up I was on the impression I was
adopted a lot of kids have that
insecurity and feel for whatever reason
that they were adopted and I was one of
those children is about nine years old
finally I asked my parents I said mom
dad I don't know why but I think I'm
adopted am i they both chuckle and my
dad said to me ha ching cha wa ha have a
girlfriend I've been going out with my
girlfriend for sex I farted in a full
lift today which was wrong on so many
levels
parents have differing views when it
comes to dogs when I was a kid my
parents say we could get a puppy if we
hated it we could just abandon it my
foster parents however
should midgets be paid under the table
and my family on the youngest of three
my parents are both older
so many people are jumping on the Barack
Obama bandwagon which as an African
American really offends me my god has a
weird hobby collects empty bottles which
sounds so much better than alcoholic
doesn't it I was involved in a one-night
stand that went horribly wrong we've
been married three years now my
girlfriend says I'm afraid of commitment
while she's not my girlfriend it's more
a wife went for Roma therapy today
aromatherapist walked into the room
farted and said that would be fifty
bucks
people can be so ignorant towards other
nationalities I'm thin I don't play the
banjo I don't have sex with my cousin
and still people assume I'm American my
wife has an ass like JLo no jello
but what if dolphins don't want to swim
with [ __ ] people I don't think I got
the job at Microsoft they haven't
responded to my telegram standing in the
park today wondering why does a frisbee
appear larger the closer it gets and
then it hit me no I was horrible in
school I failed math so many times I
can't even count I was good at history
know anybody who accuses me of stealing
other comedians jokes can kiss my black
ass okay tried phone sex recently got my
phone builds the other day there 852
dollars man don't call stuttering [ __ ]
receiving oral sex from an ugly persons
like rock climbing you should never look
down I've decided we don't want children
if anybody does we can drop them off
tomorrow I'm not ashamed of my wife if
you don't believe me go to the car and
ask her I don't know what went wrong
with me and my last girlfriend or Toby
as I called her we have a beautiful
little girl who we named after my mom in
fact passive aggressive psycho turns
five tomorrow I'm Canadian although I
truly do feel British because both my
parents are alcoholics I hope you're
doing okay money-wise I'm set for life
provide I die next Tuesday
my girlfriend thinks I'm incapable of
being faithful my wife on the other hand
as a sister I wouldn't mind
I preferred French over chemistry
because the chemistry teacher and I just
didn't have any I like what mechanics
wear overall so much nudity on TV I just
sit there shaking my fist no I'm lazy
I'm so lazy um I didn't write a punch I
was raised by my father my mother left
before I was born and oh they're
building an Ikea in my neighborhood
every time I Drive by I feel sorry for
the construction workers
[Music]
I have never asked a rhetorical question
how cool is that
I read that ten out of two people are
dyslexic my father was a man of few
words I remember used to say to me son
did your trunks were going to the
library
my sexual fantasy is to make love to
Sigmund Freud's father mother got a lot
of couples here tonight I love blind
dates kids getting stared their tits
like most Canadians I like to go
clubbing but if there's no seals around
I went to university on a swimming
scholarship and university I was going
to join the debating team but someone
talked me out of it when I was a kid my
fairy godmother asked me if I wanted a
long penis or a long memory I forget my
response I think women who think size
doesn't matter are shallow I quit my job
at the helium gas Factory I refused to
be spoken to in that tone
you are looking at a very proud Canadian
who's very proud of the education system
in Canadia I think it's the goodest of
all 17 countries my grandma who's
addicted to tea hates the way I say
things she doesn't enjoy my visit is my
wife dissatisfied with my body a tiny
part of me says yes
and it's often thought that a man's
sexual fantasy is to be involved in a
threesome and I thought it was mine
until recently I was involved in a
threesome I'll be honest with you ladies
and gentlemen I didn't enjoy it halfway
through I stopped and said listen Rick
Jim